every day we will celebrate some of the
best science has to offer in
2020 and we will experience the
breakthrough
of the year across 10 disciplines
distinguished juries will join us and
our first category today is
life science and i'm now connected
virtually with the jury chair of this
category
maria makarov director of biocentre of
finland it's great to have you with us
hello how are you thank you hello
makarov could you describe what was
actually your
job leading the jury for this category
life sciences
thank you yes indeed so the job of the
chair
is to lead the evaluation work by
drawing from the specific
expertise areas of each of the jury
members and then amalgamating these
knowledge areas into high collective
intelligence
can you give us a sneak peek into the
upcoming winter sessions what were the
hop
topics what are the issues yes indeed
we had 64 proposals all in all
and those hot topics could be perhaps
listed as as follows
so the first category new antibiotics
new vaccines new drugs then brain
research
and therapies for brain cancer gut
microbiology
medical technology plant biotechnology
and evidently coronavirus and kobe 19
related topics i guess
it was quite difficult to find out the
winners
what were actually the criteria for
finding the most innovative
contributions
well the criteria were extremely
demanding first of all
excellent science but this was not
enough because the research findings had
to be translated into innovations
that benefit society societal impact was
sought for
and it in the best cases the innovations
were groundbreaking meaning that they
were something totally new opening up
new avenues do you have
uh maybe a recent favorite example of a
real breakthrough in your field
well i would like to mention the gene
scissors
the crispr cast 9 technology which will
be awarded
the nomel prize on the 8th of december
and this is
absolutely groundbreaking science
paradigm shifting science and then
innovations which will impact us
from public health to plant
biotechnology
so let's see what sorry what kind of
breakthroughs
we will find during the winter sessions
today thank you so much for the moment
mr
mrs makarov we will talk to you later
thanks a lot